foreign  for what your daddy passed down to you  but I wanted a child  [Music]  gift of my life  I'm visiting my mother tomorrow  hi Karen it's Mom I'm just calling to  say that I'm so so so excited to see you  tomorrow you're my angel and I love you  okay I love you okay bye sweetie I love  you  are you at the airport I'm on my way I  just  it's not safe is it  what do you think I should do I'm sure  you'll do the right thing sweetheart  welcome back  I hit you with my car what I know  what what is this that's my little  assistant health monitor  feeling sad about going home both  [Music]  feel totally unreal  you're supposed to be leaving I don't  know if that's gonna happen  [Music]  you will walk many miles  dozens will become a hundred  [Music]  s will become thousands  your adventures will continue for years  and years this is a good hole I know  [Music]  devotion it's not for me  [Music]  do you want the truth now  [Music]